Nos dicen: "Ricardo hará un viaje por carretera
de 100 kilómetros de largo. Su velocidad promedio
es de 70 kilómetros por hora. A esa velocidad,
puede manejar 5 kilómetros por cada litro de
combustible que utilice. El combustible cuesta
0.60 dólares por litro", lo equivalente a 60
centavos por litro, pero lo escribieron como
0.60 dólares por litro, "¿Cuál es el costo del
combustible en todo el viaje?" Pausa el video e
intenta encontrar la respuesta. Bien, veamos qué
información nos dan. Nos dicen que el viaje es de
100 kilómetros de largo -100 km-, además nos dicen
que su velocidad promedio es de 70 kilómetros
por hora -70 km / h-, también nos dicen que,
a esa velocidad puede manejar 5 kilómetros por
cada litro de combustible que utilice -5 km / l-,
por último nos dicen que el combustible
cuesta 0.60 dólares por litro -0.60 dólares /
l. Normalmente se escribe como 60 centavos por
litro, pero trabajamos lo de esta forma. Ahora
bien, ¿qué información es útil para obtener el
costo total del combustible en todo el viaje?
Bueno, tenemos que encontrar cuánto combustible
va a utilizar y después multiplicarlo por el costo
del combustible, así que ¿cuánto combustible
utilizará? Bueno, tenemos una distancia total
de 100 km y este otro dato nos dice, básicamente,
cuántos litros utilizará en esos 100 km, y puedes
preguntarte ¿cómo funciona eso exactamente?
Bueno, si sabemos que recorre 5 km / l y
tomamos el recíproco de este dato, obtenemos que
se utiliza 1/5 de l / km: esta es la cantidad de
combustible que se utiliza por kilómetro, 1/5 l.
¿Y esto por qué es útil? Porque si tomamos 100 km
y lo multiplicamos por 1/5 l / km, esto nos dirá
que durante el transcurso del viaje usaremos 100
x 1/5 l, es decir, durante el transcurso del viaje
se utilizarán 20 litros. Después, si multiplicamos
esto por el costo del combustible por litro,
obtendremos el costo total del viaje. Hagámoslo,
multipliquemos esto por 0.60 dólares por litro,
que es lo mismo que esto por 0.60 dólares por
litro, los litros se cancelan, y podemos ver
que nuestras unidades son adecuadas, nuestra
respuesta tendrá como unidades los dólares, y
20 x 0.60 nos dará 12, obtenemos 12 dólares.
Y lo logramos: este es el costo total del
viaje. Y tal vez estés pensando: "Espera,
no hemos usado toda la información que nos dan, no
hemos usado el dato que nos dice que su velocidad
promedio es de 70 kilómetros por hora", y es
cierto, no lo utilizamos en nuestros cálculos,
aunque fue útil porque necesitábamos saber cuál
era la eficiencia del combustible a esa velocidad,
por eso nos dicen: "su velocidad promedio es
de 70 kilómetros por hora", a esa velocidad
tenemos esta eficiencia del combustible.
Ahora, ni siquiera tenían que decirnos esto,
podrían habernos dicho que "a cierta velocidad
la eficiencia del combustible es esta" y de
cualquier manera aún hubiéramos podido encontrar
el costo total del combustible en todo el viaje.